foreign
Ethan kicks it off in Orlando Ethan
welcome to the Ramsey show my friend how
you doing
what's going on uh something I'm
wondering about is my roommate isn't
quite able to make the rent every month
and I'm wondering how I can get him on a
budget and then uh if at the end of the
lease he's not able to to pay back the
money we've lent them over time do I
just write that off as stupid tax or or
hope that he can end up paying me back
he's not able to or he doesn't want to
I don't know he makes room for his
groceries and his other stuff that he
ends up being late every month on the
ramp what's his reaction like like are
you like buddies with this guy or is
this like a true like roommate we found
this guy on Craigslist
uh yeah the three of us we've all been
friends uh for several years since you
know early High School
when he when he can't pay like what what
does he say is he just constantly
bumming money off you guys is he
remorseful or do does he like slap in
his pockets like oh man yeah
yeah he seems a little sorry but he more
just lets us discover oh looks like we
got a late fee what okay well we haven't
paid on time okay why did that happen
who who's this money getting paid to
who's the landlord
uh this like you know huge you know
renting company
well I think that's the next step if
this guy can't pay is they get to evict
him because he's not making rent and you
find a new roommate who can and you have
that hard conversation
okay because it seemed it felt more like
from their perspective the the company
that it's more like you know total bill
needs to be paid and they don't care who
pays it but you think you're saying it's
more like a can they split it into
different payments or do they need it
all as one giant lump sum and they go
hey you roommates you figure out who's
who's gonna actually write that check
we all have accounts on their website
but they just see what it is at the end
of the month it's just one tab that
we're all chipping into
I would talk to them and say Hey listen
we're on the lease two of us are paying
just fine this guy's not what are our
options here
because right now you're just enabling
him by allowing him to take this
interest-free loan every month I mean
how how far behind is he on rent
uh in total it's like fifteen hundred
dollars
because he hasn't paid he's never paid
the electricity bill what
how is he okay with this
because we've been patient with them but
you know after these few months you
don't be patient with idiots they'll
drag you down with them this guy's a
grifter yeah
how have these conversations gone like
have you had these real conversations
with him or you're just like hey dude
like we can't keep doing this
yeah what we've done is I've given them
like payment plans where we say all
right we're going to do this much this
month this much that month and I
projected out for him for the whole year
and he's like gee thanks and then
um next month he didn't quite make it
it's like well what happened to the
payment plan he's like okay okay
even the fact that he says gee thanks
like his response to your generosity and
to you floating him this money is G
thanks is there's not respect there dude
I I'd have his mattress on the lawn and
change the locks and say you don't live
here until you pay rent
and that's not because I'm a bad friend
or whatever he's putting you guys in a
terrible Financial spot and now using
you
to enable his stupid Behavior
I don't know that you can legally put
the mattress on the line listen I don't
know you can legally not pay rent for a
year and make your friends give you
loans and put you on payment plans even
though you're not the landlord well
that's where I would change it from a
friendship relationship where this is
all one group of friends paying rent and
like George said I would call the
landlord and say okay this dude's not
paying we may need to evict him we need
to figure this out like we need to know
our options I'm gonna say you've got one
month to come up with that 1500 bucks
you owe and then you are on time every
single month in fact you're early and if
you're not you can't live here anymore
because we need someone who pays
reliably on time that was the agreement
when you signed that lease are you
willing to have this conversation
because part of it is like George said
to the enabling like this is not a
budget meeting this guy doesn't want to
pay
and he's not really being your friend
like the fact that he's putting you in
this financial situation and really
taking advantage of you is not a good
friendship
and if that's why I'm saying if you go
to the company and make them the bad guy
that will at least put some fuel on this
thing
yeah I can imagine that he doesn't quite
notice the gravity of it like if he
didn't have such nice friends he would
be evicted like you that would have
happened exactly but you know what
happens when you do it one month in the
next month it just becomes normal
and so he gets used to stupidity instead
of having to actually change his
behavior I mean this guy's working right
he's making money
yeah he works at like an oil change
place and if he can't afford to live
there he just needs to find a new place
to live it's not a because I'm a bad
friend you guys can still be friends
with him when he moves out in fact
you're probably better friends with him
when you're not part of his landlord
situation
yeah it's made things awkward
yeah what's your rent what's the cost
I totaled 24.50 a month and you guys
split that three with another like 100.
yeah well I pay a little bit more since
I have the master bedroom but yeah okay
so what's his share 700 bucks
uh not uh yeah he plays like 790 and
then another like you know 60 or
whatever in utilities and he's not
paying electricity for some reason
yeah he just hasn't done that yet when
does this lease end
at the very end of August
okay and are you planning to renew this
lease I hope I know the answer
no we definitely can't you know yeah he
needs to be calm the back of my brain
wanted me to you know find a place
that's two thousand dollars a month with
them but you know when I asked them okay
what can you afford he's like I guess
700 and it's like well what do you mean
you guessed that's you need a budget
I mean you're I'm happy to gift you
Total Money Makeover to give to him I
don't think this guy is gonna crack the
cover of it to be honest
because he doesn't want to change
he's not coming to you for financial
advice he's coming to you for handouts
has he has he once said man I'm just my
paychecks are tight can you help me
figure this out has he once said that
no he's never had me sit down with him
I think that's very he never asked me to
mm-hmm
I think you need to channel your inner
George energy dude I get aggressive with
him my little man syndrome comes out in
these situations I'm just not putting up
with that crap
your your life is too important your
financial future is too important to let
this goober stick around and put you in
a bind with this weird personal loan
situation where now you have to start
hassling him for the money going Where's
My Money where's my money I'll get it to
you next month bro
he's out you're also not his parent the
fact that you're like trying to talk to
him about money and he's like gee thanks
that's like something that like a child
would say to their mother like not two
grown adult friends
I'm fuming right now I'm sorry Ethan you
gotta go through this find better
friends is A1 but next step let's get
this guy out of here